[Música]
Esto es lo que quedó del vuelo 447 de
Air France tras estrellarse en el
Atlántico cuando cumplía la ruta Río de
Janeiro París en junio de 2009
228 personas perdieron la vida en la que
fue la peor catástrofe de ver France más
de 13 años después el caso finalmente
llega a juicio un momento doloroso para
las familias de las víctimas el primero
de junio fuimos al aeropuerto a recibir
a Eric y vamos a celebrar su cumpleaños
número 38 el 22 de junio tenía toda la
vida por delante las familias molestas
por la negación de la responsabilidad de
Air France y airbus quieren determinar
quién tuvo la culpa
nos hubiera gustado que existiera un
mínimo de empatía por parte de las dos
compañías pero se han contentado con
decir durante toda la investigación que
lo hicieron todo bien y que fue culpa de
los pilotos o simplemente mala suerte
eso es algo que las familias de las
víctimas no pueden aceptar
esta fue la última imagen del avión
antes de despegar unas horas más tarde
el vuelo 447 se encontró con una
violenta tormenta los tubos pitón del
avión que miden la velocidad de la
aeronave se congelaron y dieron lecturas
contradictorias los pilotos se
desorientaron por una sucesión de
alarmas
[Música]
el avión se detuvo y entró en caída
libre durante tres minutos y medio antes
de golpear la superficie del océano y
romperse
quién tuvo la culpa airbase están siendo
juzgados por homicidio involuntario
acusados de haber subestimado el mal
funcionamiento de los tubos pitot y de
no haber informado a la tripulación de
incidentes anteriores se espera que el
juicio de dos meses contenga muchos
detalles técnicos tanto airbus como Air
France se declaran inocentes